e
e e
it's let me start over here this is a
Community Conference for HB 1386 an act
relative to prohibiting the disposal of
lithium ion batteries and solid waste
landfill facilities composting
facilities or
incinerators and we've all
been charged to come here today and uh
fix the difference that happened uh we
had the house version that went over to
the Senate and the Senate amended it and
I don't know if there was uh drafting
errors or whatever but um there was
definitely some problems with the
resulting version from the
Senate and I would uh now turn this over
to representative eil who eel who is the
Prime sponsor of this bill to explain um
what happened and what needs to be fixed
to fix it okay all right there are very
few differences between the house
version and the Senate version um but
where this started was during the
hearing on HB
1386 um a staff person from uh the dees
uh noted that there were a couple of
typographical type uh errors that should
be fixed so uh one was inserting the
word or in the definition of computer
and the other one was replacing the term
used as with used with in the definition
of computer monitor that was it and so
um a amendment was requested to correct
that and unfortunately although the
language of the amendment was correct
the way it was set up it said that we
were going to amend
1386 by replacing in the house version
of the bill sections five and
six so what happened was uh the
definition of computer which was in
section four remained in the Senate bill
so when the Senate version of the bill
came out it had the it had two
definitions of computer in it one the
old one and one the new
one um so there the Senate version now
has two ver two definitions of computer
one of which needs to be removed in my
opinion um and then the other thing um
that I
did that was done as part of the um as
part of the drafting of the
bill in the
statute uh section four was combined
with section two section four had to do
with um with ewaste and section two was
the one that had this the information
about wet cell batteries that we added
to so by combining four and
two um section uh we basically had to
get rid of the old section four and
unfortunately in the Senate process the
necessary repeal language was deleted
and so in my
Amendment um I've reinstated the repeal
the necessary repeal
language so I can show you uh basically
the the in my Amendment if you've got it
H um we also discovered that there was
another missing or and another
word there's a lot of ores in here so
what's new here so first of all okay so
the old comp old definition of computer
is being
removed um and in the and then on line
five before the word electrochemical
I've got the word or and after the word
electrical chemical I've got the word
data so this all makes sense on line six
before the word storage we've added the
word
or on the word on line 11 before the
term a computer we have used with and
then on line not uh 14 I've reinstated
the necessary repeal language and that's
basically it that's the only
difference I mean really the the the
Senate amendment was fine it's just the
way I don't think any of us focused on
the fact that they were inserting it as
section they were replacing sections
five and six um and it kind of messed
and there was no renumbering and it kind
of messed with everything so it's
basically a shift represent BBY so um
procedurally is the next thing we do
make a motion to accept the amendment
well I'd like to hear from rep uh
Senator Pearl on his thoughts on this
good morning good morning thank you
representative evil looks like you did a
good job the fixing and cleaning up the
error that was made I think it was just
a drafting error as you stated because
this this seems to
uh seems to further the intent of the
Senate what we were trying to do by I'm
reading it and doing a little clean up
here so I I don't think we'd have any
objection to this so you'd be fine with
the amendment yes okay um so then I
guess uh as a as a body of committee
here shall we uh make a motion to accept
the amendment so move second okay um so
let me uh let me put here
so represent Craton moves
to
adopt um
Amendment
246h
and oh you second you you you moved okay
pleas be
moved
okay so um I guess I don't need to call
the role but
and everybody anybody uh who who all is
in favor of adopting the amendment say I
I I
I well we don't all vote together okay
you you vote as a house the Senate will
any Nays
no okay so the house is is agreed to the
amendment and and the Senate will agree
to adopt this amendment to amend the
Senate version okay
okay all right so we will we're both
adopting the amendment and I guess there
any any other question or concern about
this no nope then I'm move that we
adjourn this Committee of conference and
uh and adopt this am have this amendment
adopted and I will uh write up the
committee report and we should be all
done
excellent okay right all right if you
guys are good nine minutes good job all
right Madam chair we're good I'm going
to I'm going back to the other one that
started night thank
you
e e